on Prime crime one of my employees has
not shown up to work for three days
brutal murders in a family home in the
early stages no there was no suspects we
didn't know who might have done this we
didn't have a clue in a case that brings
Whispers of dark magic to a quiet
coastal town I would not harm my
family's her for nothing yeah
thank you
hey everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases a family is
found slaughtered and it's the way they
were killed that creates a whole new set
of questions
and I wanted her emergency
[Music]
what uh has not shown up for work for
three days so I came out to his house
it's July of 2015. 47 year old Richard
RT Smith is living with his 77 year old
mother Von seal Bonnie Smith and his
brother 49 year old John William Smith
on a quiet dead-end street in Pensacola
Florida
his car's here doors are all locked the
windows shades are all drawn but RT
hasn't been heard from in a few days and
this causes his co-worker some alarm
they were described as very reclusive
type people they stay to themselves they
didn't socialize much outside of their
own family once authorities arrive they
realize the doors are locked but with
the help of the fire department they
gain access to the home there was a lot
of stuff in the house
almost like hoarding it was full it was
full of a lifetime of collecting
memorabilia and personal belongings that
didn't look like there was a sign of a
struggle there was no signs that it was
a robbery I mean there was money there
was jewelry it didn't seem anything was
out of place what appears to just be an
odd home immediately turns into a
gruesome crime scene all their throats
were slashed they were bludgeoned with a
claw hammer and the mother's fingertip
was cut off
and only Richard was shot in the head RT
Von seal and John are all found dead
their bodies in various rooms of the
house
investigators say the victims had been
there for at least a couple of days we
didn't know who might have done this we
didn't know if it had anything to do
with Richard's job at Homeland Security
or what we didn't have a clue and that's
when Von Seal's third son from a
different marriage comes into the
picture Donald Hartung showed up to the
scene the day that the police arrived he
was questioned as is every family member
in any homicide case interviewing him it
was really trying to get as much
information as I could about the family
he was the only other family member
around that we could find when was the
last time you saw your family
Tuesday I got there probably about 1 or
1 30. I fixed dinner for him every
Tuesday I always put Ortiz in the stove
was he there when you were there Tuesday
no I never saw RT
most of the time I leave before he gets
home every Tuesday he went to the Smith
family residence he always took his dog
he went there every week to cook dinner
for his family what time did you leave
you think normally we watched the
national news at 5 30 at 5 30 and then I
leave right after that where'd you go
after that home that's when the
interview takes a curious turn did they
tell you how your your folks your family
over there was killed
killed
they said they were the station and they
never told me how they were killed
they're dead and it looks like they were
killed
thank you
he almost like questioned me like he
just repeated it to me deceased and I
was like yes they were killed how would
they killed it's hard to tell because
there was a lot of clothes on top of
them
clothes on top of them
oh my God
were they robbed
I don't think so in every case
especially a homicide anyone's a suspect
everyone's a suspect why would somebody
go in there and kill your mom and your
two brothers and
put clothes on them like that to me it
seems like somebody that would do
something like that
would have known him or either been
family because they didn't want to see
them after they were dead that makes
sense to me but
as far as I know I'm the only family
they got up next the investigation into
the Smith family murders heats up now I
have to sit here and try and figure out
who killed your mother and your two
brothers yes you do and I hope you do it
soon
[Music]
you've shown no emotion the whole time
you've been in here
it's like you almost prepared yourself
for this I'll show plenty of emotion
when the time's right it's the summer of
2015 and authorities are investigating a
mysterious triple homicide in which a
Florida family were violently killed in
their home Von seal Bonnie Smith along
with her two sons John and Richard RT
Smith were savagely murdered
investigators believe Donald Hartung Von
Seal's son from another marriage was
perhaps the last person to see them
alive after their weekly family dinner
Hartung sits down with special agent
Matt infinger in a series of interviews
where hartung's Behavior comes into
Focus how does it make you feel to hear
that your family was killed
pretty bad
I mean the old scene
well I'm not upset I've got to control
myself here okay I've got to take care
of this usually people show two types of
emotion they're either emotional like
visibly upset crying or they become
angry he shouldn't either he was
cooperating and maybe in his mind if I
cooperate I'll be kind of involved in
the process and I'll know what's going
on some people handle shock and Trauma
differently were you having problems
with the middle no
so some didn't happen when you were over
there Tuesday night and you killed them
no
because if something happened Now's the
Time to tell me I went at him hard a few
times just to see how he would react or
what he would say looks like
Brother John
was just sitting there watching TV
somebody just shot him while he was
sitting in his chair
and then your mother
was sitting in her chair
somebody shot her
then dragged her back to her bedroom
oh my God when I would accuse him or try
and pin him down on things he didn't
become angry you were probably still
there
and then RT comes home
me yeah I didn't do it I didn't kill my
family it felt like to me that he had
almost prepared himself for the
interview that he knew something like
this was going to happen
these people you killed your family no
why I did not kill my family yes you did
no I didn't I'm kind of feeling like I'm
being accused of something here that I
am accusing you of doing it I think you
did it I did not do it the conversation
takes an interesting detour when police
find something strange at hartung's
house I guess you have a Ouija board and
some stuff in your house yeah I do have
a Ouija board are you wicking or yeah
I'm a wicked it was done two days before
the the so-called Blue Moon it did
become a thing that this was ritualistic
and these ceremonies or whatever you do
do you have anything like
sacrifices or anything
now there's no sacrifices and look
really no the bodies were all in
separate rooms the placement of the
bodies and how the bodies were presumed
to have blankets on top of the bodies to
keep them warm they drained the blood
out of their sacrifice
and hit him in the head
then they cover them that's the same way
your family was killed
they were what
why don't you tell me what you did to
him the Wicca Community actually
responded to it and said that this is
has nothing to do with what we practice
and in fact we don't condone ritual
killings as we as prosecutors got
to the case we did not believe
[Music]
some sort of ritualistic killing as
initially believed coming up
investigators believe they have their
suspect but he's adamant he didn't kill
his family could there be truth to what
Hartung is saying I promise this I'm
gonna find out
I'm gonna find out I'm gonna put your
ass in jail I would not harm my family
sir for nothing in this world
thank you
[Music]
why don't you kill him why would I kill
him why did you I did not kill my family
sir to die I did not kill him a
Pensacola Florida family is murdered in
Cold Blood In The Summer of 2015. Von
sealed Bonnie Smith and her two sons
John and Richard RT Smith hadn't been
heard from in several days until their
bodies are discovered inside their
locked home investigators questioned Von
Seal's son from a prior marriage Donald
Hartung they believe he was the last
person to see them alive days earlier
but he says he didn't hurt them
special agent Matt and finger is not
buying his story I didn't do anything to
my family yeah you did and you killed
them all the same way
stab them stabbing they were stabbed
God then there's the question of DNA a
pivotal piece of evidence in many cases
but perhaps DNA can only go so far in
this case he claimed that he was always
at that house so having his DNA all over
the home wasn't something bizarre
however there were a few things that
stood out do you smoke yes I do what do
you do with the cigarettes when you're
done with them throw them in the trash
there was cigarette butts in different
levels of the trash can in the laundry
room once we got the DNA back on those
they were Donald's the way it was
positioned was obviously suspect it was
on top of some bloody items and some
personal belongings of on Sills did you
touch
any of RT's belongings
Ortiz belonging you know so we located
Richard's binder Donald's DNA was on
Richard's checkbook which was inside
that binder I don't mess with nothing of
RTS we would expect that Donald DNA
would be within the family home however
it was the places that
where it should not have been there was
also a hammer that was found on the side
of the sink that we believe was washed
and that had actually all of the family
members DNA on that I mean do I look
like some kind of a bloom in Maniac to
you people
I mean you me in finger Narrows in on
Hartung revealing an unexpected
observation from other Witnesses
neighbors saying nobody comes and goes
over there
the only person I ever see come and go
over there is you they kind of kept it
themselves they really weren't involved
with the rest of the community it was
kind of known that they didn't really
let Outsiders into their home nobody has
seen these people since Tuesday
since you saw so how are you going to
sit there and tell us that you didn't
kill them
when you were the last one to see him
they trust in you
and you killed them I would never harm
my mother never hurt my brothers never
could Donald Hartung have killed his own
family the question would be why does it
say my mom loved your half Brothers more
than she loves you no never
would you be surprised if I told you
that she spent six thousand dollars last
month on a QVC
be shocked would you be mad that your
inheritance has been blown on QVC hell
no I don't give a damn about no
inheritance he was
at the time he was making maybe ten
dollars an hour working as a security
guard for a hospital we discovered that
Donald really wasn't living that
comfortably he didn't have a lot of
money he was basically living paycheck
to paycheck does Mom have an insurance
policy
I don't know
does Mom have a will
I think she has a will
but I've never seen it they never found
a copy of the will in his home or on any
of his electronic devices so there's no
concrete proof that he even knew
there was a will do you know what you're
entitled to on that will I have no idea
what I'm entitled to in any will
be common knowledge for anyone to know
that if his entire family
was deceased he would be the sole heir
to their estate you realize on something
case like this the insurance company
calls the Sheriff's Office and wants to
know if you're a suspect
so you're insinuating that I killed my
family to get their life insurance
policy do I look like a total maniac to
you people
yeah
the way you're acting yeah yes within
three weeks of his family being murdered
he actually resigned from his place of
employment I don't know are you a
cold-blooded killer
oh sir I'm not a cold-blooded killer on
October 27 2015 after a three-month-long
investigation police announced an arrest
Donald Hartung is charged with three
counts of first-degree murder and is
faced with a possible sentence of death
we were certain that Donald Hartung was
the only person who could have committed
this crime the motive in this case came
down to simple greed he wanted money
when we return it's the murder trial of
Donald Hartung yet do prosecutors really
have enough to convince a jury he's
guilty they never found the murder
weapon there were no Witnesses nobody
actually saw him do anything all they
had were these little bits of evidence
[Music]
you know
exactly what's going on
oh I know I know what's happened
exactly you do know what's happened
because you were there when it happened
because her I was not in the summer of
2015 three members of the Smith family
were brutally murdered in their
Pensacola Florida home
authorities discover the bodies of
vancio Bonnie Smith along with two of
her three sons John and Richard RT Smith
beaten stabbed and RT even shot after a
series of interviews and a collection of
evidence investigators arrest their
suspect Von Seal's third son Donald
Hartung nearly five years after the
killings in January 2020 prosecutors
began laying out their case against
Hartung this family
was brutally and violently murdered by
this defendant
and the evidence will show ladies and
gentlemen that he did it all for their
money
his mother left everything to his two
brothers John and Richard
she specifically excluded him from her
will
and what you will see during the course
of this trial through evidence is that
for him to get anything
they all three had to Die the strongest
evidence in the case that pointed toward
Donald Hartung was the DNA we found DNA
on the underside of Richard's belt which
had been kind of lifted up like his body
maybe had been moved
we also found Donald's DNA on a it was a
little case that Richard used to carry
with him all the time some of the
contents of the bag had Donald hartungus
DNA that should have not been there but
prosecutors have something else up their
sleeve before trial they received new
information from hartung's cellmate
during the autopsy of vonsil Smith it
was discovered her one of her pinkies
was cut off we all believed that the
finger injury was probably a defensive
wound but then the cellmate of Donald
Hartung told us that the finger was
actually cut as a form of torture and
who better to tell this than hartung's
cellmate himself
did he tell you anything about what his
relationship was like with his mother
his mother she left him at the wheel
that really made him mad he said
probably the easiest piece of evidence
in the case the informant in the jail
telling us everything that Donald had
confided in him about the murder did he
tell you who killed his mother and two
brothers he said he killed him he said
he won't he want the money because she
left him out the wheel he made mention
of things that we knew he would not have
known just by looking at paperwork or
looking at any of hartung's Discovery he
went to his mother he
torture Hood so she can tell the
combination for the safes he told me
that uh
he put clothes in the body so they
couldn't tell the time the death the can
the jury trust testimony from a man who
faced serious charges himself of assault
with a hammer that's exactly what
hartung's defense jumped on is he
credible you testified earlier that that
that Mr Hartung was angry because his
mother had written Mr hartung's son out
of the will
no win both no matter where him and his
son that's not what you said in that
first interview correct
I can't recall well did the truth change
we're always a little leery and probably
reluctant because cellmates or jail
informants typically want something in
return and they have credibility issues
and the defense didn't end there none of
the investigators had any suspect beside
my client
they didn't bother looking at anyone
else hartung's attorney brought in their
own forensic pathologist to challenge
the original timeline can you say within
a reasonable degree of scientific
certainty these bodies were not killed
on Tuesday
I cannot tell you it's impossible I can
tell you that Tuesday is inconsistent
with the scientific and medical evidence
I believe that there was some Doubt cast
by the defense I didn't think it was a
slam dunk case for either side after
four hours of deliberations the
12-person jury reached their verdict we
the jury find the defendant daughter
Parts on guilty of first-degree murder
as charged and indictment it was
satisfying to see him get found guilty
there was a lot of uneasiness in the
community when this happened this you
know doesn't occur every day but that
wasn't the end for Donald Hartung as he
still had to learn if the jury would
choose life or death during his penalty
phase but before he sentenced he makes
an interesting move one even his
attorneys were unaware of council wants
anything before he starts talking
no idea what it's going to say Mr
Griffin didn't even discuss the surface
I respectfully request
I believe that he was a bit of a
narcissist I think that he thought he
could outsmart the prosecution I loved
my jury they paid attention they paid
close attention
but you're honor they would do you were
too there's been no evidence that Mr
President or Ms Wilson have been
ineffective after two days of the
prosecution arguing for the death
penalty the jury made a decision
eligibility for the dead County with the
jury and Ashley find that the
aggravating factors that were going to
Beyond a reasonable adult section A
outweigh the mitigating circumstances no
I'll send you a life in prison on each
cow we were disappointed with the
sentence as we felt death was an
appropriate sentence but we also
understood that it is very difficult
decision for a jury to make unanimously
Prosecuting this case was very difficult
but it was very rewarding the relief
came in this case knowing that all of
our hard work had finally paid off and
that the victims in this case received
Justice
clearly this wasn't an easy case
especially since there really wasn't a
Smoking Gun you know that one piece of
evidence that's short of convict yet
when all the pieces of the puzzle
finally were put together the jury came
back and found Donald Hartung guilty
bringing Justice for Von seal John
Richard and the rest of the extended
family
thanks for joining us here on Prime
crime until next time stay safe
[Music]